all right guys bang-bang what's going on
lunch money time well while she's trying
to get rich the rest of us just try to
get our lunch money right I am here with
the beautiful and intelligent plenum era
Nova she has the uniform on finally
she's paying attention she's following
the rules all black everything
don't forget the shows now sponsored by
block five huge shout out to the team at
block Phi get money get paid they're
trying to get you paid
they've got three products the first
allows you to deposit crypto you get a
u.s. dollar loan the second allows you
to buy and sell crypto currencies and
the third is my favorite I'm an investor
in the company and a user of the product
which is you can earn up to eight point
six percent APY literally you can go
deposit cash or crypto and get money get
paid I love money
yeah it's our thing now you know
anything you have is mine anything I
have is yours
speaking of Softbank the trademark but
go ahead you can copyright whatever you
want go ahead Softbank what's up
Softbank is we have an issue we have an
issue
planta just knocked over all of her
coffee on my entire joe positive
alright guys hold on a second we're back
Polina just spilled coffee I was like
following the rules with my black shirt
so I decide to break some rules by you
know messing up his notebook with all
the coffee
I just everything's really I don't know
what to do right now we're gonna discuss
this later and you have calm let's talk
that's what you get if you ruin things
this is why we can't have nice things is
cuz you ruined things I've always wanted
to say that yes finally you made a mess
alright what's going on with Softbank
okay so sad you're such a nerd
go ahead is launching a hundred million
dollar opportunity growth fund to invest
in founders of color now we're stopping
getting this money because the last time
I checked it wasn't doing so hot
they're getting it off their balance
sheet one hundred million dollars for
Softbank is like twenty bucks for you
they don't have a hundred billion dollar
fund so you think about that that is one
percent of their one hundred billion
dollar fund is coming off their balance
sheet and to is look it's a great move
I'm super happy that they're gonna do it
I wish that more people would put money
towards you know women minorities black
founders everything but it's just kind
of I don't know like I I kind of feel
weird about the whole idea of like oh
there's protests going on let's launch a
fun to do this it's just like how like
how genuine I don't care if it's genuine
as long as they're getting money into
founders hands right like who cares if
Massa had this realization that only one
percent of his VC batch founders are oh
wait oh no this is this is not just it
stopping just in general one percent of
vc-backed founders are black yeah so
normally it's one percent it's very very
low so one percent I guess is what this
one says who cares if it's genuine as
long as they're pouring money into it
agreed but are you really changing
anything by saying um I have a hundred
billion dollar fund he's got a second
funds actually this is less than 1% of
all of his investable capital he's he's
basically committing less than 1% of it
right so it's even smaller percent than
normal I don't know I'd look again 100
million dollars a lot of money right but
in the grand scheme of things this to me
looks more like a marketing gimmick when
you consider they poured billions into
work that's kind of exactly all right
Warner Music IPO so the IPO market had
had kind of like a dry situation you
know it didn't have a dry situation our
kitchen table today then our kitchen
table was poppin it was like a slip and
slide with coffee
that's right but Warner Music a lot of
people don't know this Warner Music if I
remember correctly they used to be a
public company they were taking private
and now they're going public again and
the group that did that I forget who did
it they made a killing wait yes who took
them private access industries yes in
2011 for 3.3 billion and now they're
going public again do we know what the
valuation is come on you must be on top
of this stuff let's go let's go let's go
no they raised 1.9 billion and they're
selling 77 million shares 25 bucks each
so what's pretty interesting is they
brought the company private a 3.3
billion dollar valuation nine years ago
now in the IPO they've raised almost
two-thirds of that again so this is an
incredible growth for the business and
look it's it's pretty interesting
because at the end of the day musics not
going anywhere streaming is popping off
all of these companies have realized
that they use technology they can really
benefit from it he's so good for them
and you know it's really funny 2020 was
supposed to be the year that everybody
IPO all these unicorns were supposed to
go public yet proceeds from IPOs are
down 64% so far in 2020 compared for the
same period last year the whole thing
comes down to guess who didn't get a
bailout Warner Music Warner Music did
the hard work
Warner Music was disciplined they did
what they were supposed to do and then
you get reward you gotta go public you
get to go cash it in right so I don't
know why we're bailing out everybody
else but Warner Music they don't need a
bailout just a little little data point
there we needs a bailout our kitchen
table we're going to get a new kitchen
table cuz you spilled coffee all over
I need a bailout with coffee not only
did you spill the coffee on the kitchen
table it's also got on the carpet which
is gonna be a whole nother thing
for any for anybody sitting at home who
wants to know how this conversation is
gonna go in our household any time now I
make a mess I'm gonna say well lose that
instable coffee on the floor
go ahead what's going on with contact
Tracy we don't need about a one time
let's just
one time I went somewhere and he was
alone in the apartment and I got a text
message of a picture and all it said is
oh my gosh it got a little windy in here
and I was like in the apartment ago
Whitney and then I look at the picture
and it's like a spilled thing with chips
with like crumbs everywhere you know
they oh no I spilled a bunch of crumbs
all over the carb I was like opening
something and it spilled everywhere
so was it windy enough and I tried my
best to pick up as much as I could but I
didn't know where the vacuum was and so
I just took a picture and I just
admitted to my sins and said yeah I got
real windy in here I don't know how this
happened but sticking of contact tracing
what's going on come on contact tracing
let's go okay so France is rolling out
an official coronavirus contact tracing
app I'm not containing fresh outbreaks
and here's how it's gonna work
basically oh yeah so it's gonna use
low-energy Bluetooth signals to
anonymously log the nearby presence of
other users so if you come into contact
with somebody who was potentially
positive for grown rice that would ping
everybody in the store or cafe or let's
not let them do it this is not a good
idea
time out not a good idea flag not a good
idea because they can tell who you are
let me teach you guys a trick anonymous
data does not equal aggregated data this
is one of the biggest lies of the
surveillance state the aggregated data
means that they just give and for all of
the data put together you can't tell the
difference separation of it so it would
be like saying a 35% of people went to
this location that's not what they're
doing what they're doing with these
applications and also with most tracking
software is they said we give anonymous
data so they actually tracked each
individual device at the device level
and you can literally see it move
through a city they say oh we're not
going to tell you who it is though right
it's anonymous data but let me teach you
a trick
in most places New York City's a little
bit harder but in most places what
happens is people live in homes and so
they track that device and they see you
go through the city go to work do all
your stuff and then you go back to your
home will they know who lives there
either through rental agreements or
through real estate databases and so
they can figure out very quickly they
can basically D anonymize the data set
this is all a sham we don't need them
tracking anybody under the French system
the data is uploaded to government-run
centralized servers and it's so funny
they they interviewed a waiter in France
and he said he was ready to download the
app because he sees more benefits than
risks and he said to me it sounds like
wearing a mask and a shop it's easy and
it can help protect others and then they
interview a bunch of other people were
like oh my god well Paul Hubert who is
the cafe waiter isn't really a
surveillance expert so maybe we should
also put in the surveillance expert who
would say they are going to tracked you
with this and it's not good so I
understand people will say oh they're
using Bluetooth which basically means
that they're not gonna have GPS
coordinates it's all garbage it's all
garbage there was a situation I believe
it was in Tokyo don't hold me to that it
was somewhere in Asia where early on
there was a guy who was he tested
positive they went back and like the
night before something he had gone to a
nightlife area and they ended up telling
like 2,000 people hey you might have
come in contact with this person go get
tested below whatever and also they then
shut down it was something like a couple
hundred nightclubs in the area and bars
and restaurants and things like that
because this guy was simply there at
some point we have to realize you can't
stop the spread of something this you
can slow it down but it is not worth
infringing on individuals rights and in
the eyes their constitutional rights in
order to contact trace the virus it's
just it's just not possible
if we were in France I'd call the
government be like yo can you ping him
real quick he hasn't responded in my
texts can you just know let's listen
what is
coming right Tomas has talked about this
I think David Sachs has talked about
this Eric Weinstein has talked about
this is the quote-unquote biological
patriot act it's coming right they are
going to implement things that are going
to drastically increase the electronic
surveillance of citizens and it's gonna
be done under the guise of we're here to
save you
my fear is that most people are not
surveillance experts and they don't know
the implications of something like this
so they'll be like oh I can go to the
club as long as I have this app fine
I'll download it and that's how you get
a majority of people who have no idea
that they're putting themselves and
their data risk absolutely that's true
the other piece of this that's really
interesting is Joe kokis who helps us
with the show he sent me earlier today a
link where Apple has the ability
supposedly to shut off your camera or
video and the whole idea of I've got the
eye taken too many selfies well I've got
it right is basically like let's say you
were streaming a live concert and so if
you streaming it would be a violation of
copyright laws right they would be able
to stop you from doing that
well that sounds great in the music
concept kind of until what happens if
all of a sudden they say anyone in
Manhattan from 8:00 p.m. to 5:00 a.m.
during curfew hours your phone in video
doesn't work now you can't document
anything again sounds crazy but like if
I told you four weeks ago that New York
City would have a curfew from 8 p.m. to
5:00 a.m. and the cops would be out
literally arresting people for being
outside their homes I don't know
so one of the wisest thing I've ever
wisest things I've ever heard of god
what did I say no it wasn't you know but
it was it's not a thing until it's a
thing and so it's kind of like it's not
it's crazy until it I did say that to
you somebody else said it to me but I
said it to you ok anyway so it's
interesting right like everything's
crazy until it's not like who would have
thought we'd be in lockdown for 3 months
like that sounds insane but you want to
know who we are do you want to know who
thought that the idea of the government
telling us to go sit in their homes was
a bad idea me guess what
and now they're using it for other
things like oh it's a curfew so first
they called it a quarantine now they're
calling it a curfew wake up people
wake up speaking of waking up what's
going on with Google Google was sued on
Tuesday in a proposed class-action
lawsuit accusing it of illegally
invading the privacy of millions of
users by pervasively tracking their
internet use through browser set in
private mode so private mode is that tab
I open when I don't kognito oh sure is
that is that different from private I
have no idea I don't know I don't know
the details of this all I know is that
these people want five billion dollars
from Google and my guess is they're
gonna get something but they're not
gonna get five billion dollars because
if there's even a hint of truth that
Google is gathering data to Google
Analytics Google ad manager and other
things when people are on private mode
which if they're serving Google ads
means that they're collecting some sort
of data in private mode Google's gonna
lose or settle the question is just how
bad is it gonna be so look at the end of
the day are you surprised No if you want
to be off the grid get rid of your
computer get rid of your cell phone
right most people aren't gonna do that
so there is some you're giving up some
level of privacy in order to have the
convenience of using these type of
electronic devices but ultimately you've
got to decide where you're comfortable
there you know what else can have a hint
of truth they you smelled coffee on the
table know what the mouse on the spacex
not buying it not buying it they're not
they don't have super human Mouse's no
we literally sent genetically engineered
mice to space and you are over here not
believing it
I just Keita didn't put him on the
outside of the rocket one escaped what
do you think this is a season of Prison
Break yeah like an animal kingdom all
right what's going on with the tattoo
regrets all right so you know who tack
on though I got no regrets you don't
have tattoos either maybe I should go
get one with my name on it yeah yeah
loser right here or nerd no people are
very surprised that I don't have a
tattoo I'm gonna make them apologize
don't um I'll put your name right here
on my neck
go ahead okay okay
tattoo regrets so because tattoos are so
popular tattoo regrets are also very
popular are the regrets popular or the
removal popular the regret removal
process is fueling a four point eight
billion dollar industry well let's
suppose on track counter facts not that
big of an industry yes not that big huh
but but a 2015 poll found that nearly
half of Millennials and more than
one-third of Gen Xers had at least one
tattoo have one and want it removed or
just have one it's it had yeah I mean
look tattoos are nothing new but I tend
to think that there's plenty of people
who want them to get removed what I
think is more interesting I've got a
friend who I don't want to say because I
don't know if you'd be comfortable me
saying this or not we're actually I
serve on public so my friend ali hamed
who runs co-venture he's very interested
in the whole tattoo business and the
idea of tattoo parlors and kind of a
whole process around creating the tech
the idea for the tattoo whatever but
we've talked in the past about how cool
it would be if you basically could have
like a temporary tattoo and not a
temporary tattoo like oh I got it for a
day or a week or whatever but basically
a tattoo that you can put on that would
be very easily removed so it had the the
possible permanence of being there
forever if you wanted it forever but if
at some point in the future you wanted
it removed it was much easier than going
to multiple sessions oh I have a
question for you guys because I think
about this a lot would you think of me
differently if I showed up with like two
sleeves of tattoos like what would I be
treated differently like what they think
I'm a badass but I am but it's just that
would select solidify it know what why
would a tattoo make you a badass I know
I know a lot of people with tattoos that
are soft as hell why don't you just
shave your head and and put a boring I
was always curious cuz you were in the
army yet you don't have a tattoo but I
feel like most people that I who are in
the army have tattoos but yet in the
article it says in 2013 the US
banned anyone enlisting with tattoos on
the neck hands our face is that true yes
but they didn't do that before 2013 you
know why cuz they needed people they
needed bodies to send a war and they
were like look I don't care if you got
half of the ear if you got a tattoo on
your neck you got only four fingers sure
can you shoot a gun let's go they're
paying people to sign up then once they
realize hey we don't need all these
people anymore then they started to get
strict again about things like tattoos
on your neck hands and face things like
that so so basically tattoos are removed
with lasers yeah did they hurt I think
it does actually hurt you want to know
who I think it's Mark Wahlberg he had
some tattoos and he used to bring his
kids with him to the tattoo removal
process cuz painful and he would make
them sit there and watch him in tattoos
removed so they would never get a tattoo
because they could see how painful it
was to get it taken away it's pretty
crazy right all right driving disco I'm
gonna get lunch money right here these
are the ideas that I have to listen to
sometimes after she's so first of all
you destroy the carpet the kitchen table
in the chair now you want to destroy
your beautiful and now you want to
destroy your beautiful face great
drive-in disco time like drive-in disco
nope we're moving on
drive-in disco you regret no would you
um but would you still I'm over the 10
C's I don't care anymore I've moved on
I've moved on in my life would we so do
lunch money together if I got a tattoo
on my forehead yeah and all we would do
ratings would go through the roof we
just have you sit here and not talk and
just sit here and people can just look
at it every day live streaming the girl
with lunch money tattooed to her legs
hawk what would you say and everyone be
like oh who said that oh the girl with
lunch morning tattooed on her forehead
ah you got to take everything she says
with a grain of salt your judgment would
be questioned you're gonna be a very
unbiased host here Germany has kept
tonight life alive with during
coronavirus with a drive-in disco so
basically last month the world's first
drive-in disco opened outside of a club
and all these people just drove in and
watched a DJ on stage I mean kind of
kind of required you I mean how do you
day
it's in your car D just that like ID
that's how I dance I like dancing in the
car you just sit there with your hand
out the window you're going like this
and stuff you know yeah like you're
driving down the Sunset Strip in LA with
some hydraulics popping up and down in a
1967 Chevelle what up bang bang listen
to a little NWA you know got your hand
out the window let everybody know I got
some music I got some music maybe some
maybe some lights underneath the car you
know little extra effects for long dusk
hours him dancing is like truly it truly
I am I am pretty good dancer I will say
that I I think you're in an intense
dance I'm pretty good dancer don't worry
I've never lost a dance competition I
have a finisher move of all finisher
moves have I ever lost a dance
competition no you just surprise people
and they're like what the hell is going
on should I tell them what I do sure the
ultimate finisher move in a dance
competition if we're at a club at a
wedding anywhere really
you just [ __ ] walk on up to the other
contestant your competitor and at the
last second right as you get close to
them you just pop up in the air and take
your shirt and put it over their head
and it's over like you there's no coming
back and somebody crimp locks on you and
it puts their shirt over your head in a
dance competition it's game over
like just take the L go sit back down
live to fight another day he's done this
to like middle-aged ladies I've
literally probably done it a hundred
times in my life I'm undefeated in dance
competitions doesn't matter old young
male female doesn't matter I've got new
discrimination in my bones
I'll give anyone that own dance for okay
that's it for lunch money today
well while she's trying to get rid of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
Thank You block bye Thank You Polina we
will now go and discuss your sins of
spilling coffee all over our apartments
would you care that much about a mess
because this is the first time you've
ever made a mess and now I will hold on
to this for the rest of my life oh yeah
of course and don't worry I might take
pictures for the people later and show
them all the damage you did you know I'm
very hurt by this you're destroyed you
destroyed the beautiful home that we've
built
alright guys that's it for lunch money
we'll talk to you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by black 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on I'm an investor a
user and a huge fan what you're a bigger
fan of black fire than you are of me
block wise my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got 3
products they can give you a US dollar
loan you can earn up to 8.6 percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell crypto
currencies on their crypto exchange I
personally use the interest-bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to 8.6 percent
interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account go do your own
research there's risk associated but 8.6
percent it's pretty compelling so click
on the link in the description say
thanks to the folks that block by
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy plan in the comment and we'll see
you guys tomorrow and be kind to your
friends